اجتماع رباعي تركي سوري ايراني وروسي يعقد
يومي الاربعاء والخميس المقبلين في
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو التي سيحضر عنها
الممثل الخاص للرئيس الروسيه فلاديمير
بوتين في الشرق الاوسط ودول افريقيه
ميخائيل بغدانوف وعن الجانب الايراني
سيحضر مستشار الشؤون السياسيه علي اصغر
حاجه ونائب وزير الخارجيه السوريه ايمن
سوسان ممثلا النظام السوري بينما الوفد
التركي نائب وزير الخارجيه التركي بوراك
اكاجابار سيراس الوفد التركي خلال
الاجتماع هذا ما اعلنته طبعا وكاله
الاناضول التركيه
[موسيقى]
اما عن الجانب السوري تحديدا مشاهدينا
نقلت صحيفه الوطن المقربه من النظام ان
المعطيات اللازمه لانعقاد الاجتماع
الرباعي بين نواب وزراء خارجيه تركيا
وسوريا وروسيا وايران لم تنضج بعد وذكرت
الصحيفه ان موقف نظام الاسد ما زال على
حاله حتى الحصول على ضمانات تركيه تحديدا
بالانسحاب من اراضيها قبل اي لقاء سياسي
يجمع طرفين على طاوله مباحثات واحده هذا
كان عن موقف النظام لكن ماذا عن المعارضه
السوريه والتي تتخذ من تركيا مقرا رئيسا
لها هذه المعارضه ورغم تطمينات انقره
باستمرار بدعمها الا انها تبدو وكانها
منقسمه على نفسها بسبب الخلافات التي تعصف
بها داخليا والتي جعلت كل طرف من هذه
المعارضه يميل الى الموقف التركي والاخر
ضد لكن بدون القدره طبعا على التاثير
جزء اكبر من المعارضه السوريه ما يزال
يراهن على وعود تركيا بعدم التخلي عنها
وان اهدافها من التقارب ستكون تلبيه
لمصالح ولمصلحه المعارضه مؤكدين ايضا بان
انقره كانت ولا تزال الضامن والوسيط
النزيه لحل الازمه بحسب الحقوق المعارض
ياسر الفرحات طبعا هنا يعتبر اخرون ان
التقارب التركيه الروسي خنجر في خاصره
المعارضه التي ستكون الخاسر الاكبر وسوف
تفقد اهم اوراقها وهو يعني تريده دائما ان
تنتزعه من الاسد جميع الاوراق من المعارضه
طبعا سينتزعها بهذه الحاله الاسد والنظامه
[موسيقى]